المسيرات الايرانيه قد تحول احدى المدن
الاسرائيليه في اي حرب قادمه الى كياف
ثانيه تحذير اطلقه مركز ابحاث الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي لا يحتاج رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل نتنياهو التوصيه فبعودته اعاده
الضربات في العمق الايراني هجمات على
منشاه عسكريه في اصفهان تجرى فيها تجميع
صواريخ متوسطه المدى مثل شهاب القادره على
ضرب اسرائيل تل ابيب لم تعترف حتى الان
بانها المنفذ لكن مسؤولين امريكيين اكدوا
مسؤوليتها الامر اكده ايضا رونال بيرمان
في نيويورك تايمز وهو الصحفي المعروف
بصيلاته الوثيقه في اجهزه الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه الموساد نفذ العمليه
والمسيرات انطلقت من داخل ايران هذا
الاحتمال الاقرب يدعمه ان مسيره من طراز
اسرائيليه نفذت الهجوم بحسب ما اعلنته
الاجهزه الامنيه الايرانيه ولهذه الطائره
تحديدا في الفتره الاخيره سجل في استهداف
اذرع ايران الولايات المتحده نفت مشاركتها
في الضربه لكن هناك امر لافت حدثت الضربه
في نفس اليوم الذي تواجد فيه مدير
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه في
اسرائيل رجل الذي يصفه مسؤولون امريكيون
سابقون بانه الرجل المناسب للتعامل مع
الايرانيين وملفهم النووي قبل بيرنس كان
مستشار الامن القومي جيك سالبن في تل ابيب
هاتان الزيارتان مهدتان اخرى ثالثه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
الذي زار المنطقه واسرائيل في اول جوله
منذ عوده نتنياهو لمنصبه النضال المشترك
ضد ايران كان عنوان زياره بلينكل لاسرائيل
اكد مواجهه برنامج طهران النووي واستمرار
الدعم الامني لتل ابيب والواضح وبتعبير تل
ابيب الزياره
برسائل لخصوم اسرائيل
تاتي زيارتك في وقت حرج وهي تبعث رساله
واضحه لخصومنا وكذلك لشركائنا في المنطقه
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل المتحده في
ضروره مواجهه ايران وكل من يهدد السلام
والاستقرار
اخر لحادثه اصفهان الهجوم قد يكون مقدمه
لحرب للوكاله مع روسيا قد تمتد الى مساحات
اخرى خارج اوروبا بعد استهداف المنشاه
تغريده اثارت الجدل وزادت الغموض حول
المنفذ وهي لمستشار الرئيس الاوكرانيين
ميخاليو بودولياك الضربه في اصفهان مرتبطه
بالحرب في اوكرانيا وطبعا مسيره شاهد 136
الايرانيه اصبحت جزءا رئيسيا من ادوات
روسيا في حربها ضد اوكرانيا وهنا اسرائيل
قد تكون لاعبا جديدا في الحرب الاوكرانيه
والتاكيد جاء بشكل مباشر من نتنياهو ندرس
امكانيه ارسال مساعدات عسكريه بكيف
نتنياهو لفتى لامر مهم خلال المقابله التي
اجراها مع السيان ان نتصرف بطرق لن افصلها
ضد مصانع الاسلحه الايرانيه التي تستخدم
الولايات المتحده اخذت جزءا كبيرا من
الذخائر المخصصه لاسرائيل وسلمتها الى
اوكرانيا وبصراحه فان اسرائيل ايضا تتصرف
بطرق لن افصلها هنا ضد مصانع الاسلحه
الايرانيه التي تستخدم ضد اوكرانيا